ZOE CORMIER: Thank you
for taking time out
of your schedule for this.
As he mentioned, my book
covers sex, drugs, and music.
I spent three
years on this book.
It covers an enormous
range of topics.
A radio interviewer
asked me, tell me
about the sexy, druggie
research you did
when you were working on this.
And I was like, dude,
I've never done less drugs
or had less sex.
I stayed home every
night until 2:00
in the morning reading
scientific papers.
It covers a lot of stuff.
I'm only going to touch on a
few things in this lecture.
But I can probably
sum up all of it
in a quip that comes
from my mother.
I grew up in the music industry.
And my mother, who also produced
this fantastic image of me
at six months old-- some
people put their children
in teddy bear
costumes, other people
do this-- my mom is
a brilliant woman,
and she summed up three
years of academic research
with one simple point.
Most fun things in
life are bad for you
but nothing will kill you faster
than having no fun at all.
This book is not just about
the science of having fun.
It's about why these things
are important components
of the human condition.
These are not a
trivial pursuits.
And the more I
researched these topics,
the more I was
forced to question,
what does it mean to be human?
What do sex, drugs,
and rock and roll
teach us about what
it means to be human?
Usually when we
think about what it
is that demarcates our
species from other animals
we think about our so-called
higher cognitive capacities,
the capacity to do mathematics,
the ability to remember things,
the capacity to think about
the past, present, and future.
And we can tell a lot
about that from our name,
homo sapiens, the
Latin for wise man.
We think that we're
the thinky monkey.
But if you think about
scenes like this,
Jimi Hendrix at Woodstock.
I can't find any photograph
that sums it up better.
We've got Jimi, sex on legs.
We've got him on drugs.
You know he used to put
little slits in his forehead
so he could put
tabs of acid there
so he could be high the entire
time along with his audience.
And we've got 400,000
kids, OK, 400,000 people
sat in a field in upstate
New York for this gig.
We think Glastonbury
is hardcore, 150,000.
They were there for one stage.
And they didn't have
boutique camping.
They didn't have
cell phone chargers.
There was nothing
but music and drugs,
and probably a lot of sex.
So as I'm going through this,
I want you to think about,
what has science taught us
about our supposedly baser
primitive pursuits?
But what have they
done for science?
What do these teach
us about science?
So let's dive
straight in with sex.
Who here knows
the name Vesalius?
Amazing, I'm amazed how many
people don't know his name.
He's known as the
father of anatomy.
He was a Dutch anatomist
in the Renaissance era.
And he invented this.
He invented the art of
tracing the human form
in a scientific
manner and turning it
into these incredible creations.
He could elucidate the
valves of the heart.
He could trace the
circulatory system.
And he couldn't
find the clitoris.
He did not believe
that it existed.
The father of anatomy could
not find the clitoris.
When a rival of his, an
Italian named Realdo Colombo,
claimed to have
discovered it, he
believed he was the very
first man to ever find it.
He wrote a letter, and he
described it as "so pretty
and useful a thing." --so
pretty and useful a thing.
And Vesalius shot
back in a letter
to Falloppio,
Gabriele Falloppio who
also claimed to
have discovered it,
Vesalius shot back with
this, you can hardly
ascribe this new
and useless part
as if it were an organ,
to healthy women.
--key words, new and useless.
However, modern
studies have shown
that there are 8,000 nerve
endings in the clitoris,
a higher density than
you can find anywhere
outside the human body.
And it is the only
part of the human body,
and any animal as
far as we know,
that is made for only one thing.
And that is pleasure.
Moreover, recent studies have
found that, in fact, it's
a wishbone shaped structure.
It isn't just a visible nub
on the exterior of the body.
It goes down around
the mouth of the vulva.
And it appears to increase in
size and density as you age
and the more you use it.
And whenever I give lectures
to the silver-haired set, which
I often do at literary
festivals, old women, 50
or over, 70 or over, 80 or
over, look at me and go, yep.
Now let's get to your friend
and mine, the famous charmer
Sigmund Freud.
Sigmund Freud did believe in
the existence of the clitoris,
but he thought it was childish.
He thought women
would only use it
to climax if they were
immature, and they
required masturbation or some
kind of manual stimulation.
He believed that if you
were married to a man
and engaged in
penetrative sex, this
would fulfill your
biological imperative.
And you would develop into a
fully formed woman who would
come from penetration alone.
And he called this the
clitoral-vaginal transfer.
Sigmund Freud,
always the charmer.
I'm going to skip
over this next story.
But if I have time I'll
come back to it at the end
because it's a bit grim.
But it's pretty spectacular.
Now, Masters and
Johnson, most of you
probably have heard of
them because that TV show,
blah, blah, blah.
They were very famous
sex scientists.
And they did legitimize
the study of sex
in the lab, which is important.
They put people into a lab
and observed them having sex.
That is important.
However, I consider them to
be reprehensible shysters
for a number of reasons.
I'll get to a couple more.
But they said that women who
don't come from penetration
alone suffered from
sexual dysfunction.
And they used the word diseased.
The great game changer in
the history of the clitoris
is this woman, Shere Hite.
Sherry Hite was a rebel,
and she was a babe.
And she was a smart babe.
And she was a
student at Columbia.
And she, like a lot
of American students
because the tuition
is extortionate,
could not pay her tuition.
So, if I could do
it, I would do it.
She decided to
pose for "Playboy"
to make a quick buck just
so she could go to school.
She didn't know
what the picture was
going to appear like
when it was in print.
And what it was was
a photograph of her
in front of a typewriter.
And it said, the
typewriter is smart
so she doesn't have to be.
Oooh.
So what did she do?
She staged a protest in front
of "Playboy" headquarters,
demanding that the very ad she
had appeared in be removed.
How cool can you get?
She then went on to become
a verifiable scientist
in her own right.
And she conducted something
called the Hite report, 1976.
She interviewed
over 100,000 women
between the ages of 14 and 78.
And she concluded 70%, the
vast majority of women,
require direct clitoral
stimulation in order to orgasm.
It is indeed pretty and useful.
Now other people have criticized
her statistical methods,
but study after study after
study has upheld this figure.
Now when she put this
out, she received
a barrage of criticism.
"Playboy" called
it the Hate Report.
And she could do no right.
So what did she do?
She moved to Berlin, and
she's been there ever since.
Now let's get on to
the lads, the penis.
Did you know that almost every
mammal has a bone in the penis?
The boner is, in fact,
boneless in humans though.
Weirdly, we don't have a penis,
even though chimpanzees do.
Dogs and cats do.
This is the penis
bone of a walrus.
It's called an oosik, and it's
used as a weapon of warfare
by the Inuit.
So what does it mean if all
other primates have a penis
bone but we don't?
That means that other
factors are required
to insert it and keep it up.
Which other animals don't need.
They can just use the
bone for quickie mating.
So what is it that you need
to get it up and keep it up?
What's inside your ears?
If you look at the
penis inside the brain
it's quite interesting.
So modern studies
have looked at what's
called the somatosensory cortex.
So everyone in this
room has a strip
of tissue on either
side of your head.
It's a map of feeling, and it's
got different sizes apportioned
to how many nerve endings you
have in each part of your body.
So, for example, you
have a lot of room
apportioned to your
hands, a lot of room
apportioned to your feet.
If we look at where those
bits are-- you can see,
for example, the
face is quite huge
because it's very sensitive.
Weirdly, the penis is
not next to the torso.
It's next to the feet.
And some people think that
this explains the foot fetish.
That's just a theory.
But what's also true is
that, when they finally
mapped the same structures
in women-- 50 years later,
by the way.
This was in the 50s.
They didn't map women
until the early 2000s--
they found that the genitals
are next to the nipples.
And they think this is
why some women can come
from nipple stimulation alone.
Just a theory.
Now, when you turn
this into a 3-D model
it looks like this, which
is very sexy indeed.
But, of course,
when the scientists
mapped this and produced
this image, Wilder Penfield,
a Canadian, in the 1950s,
they omitted one fact.
What did they omit?
The true size of
the male member.
If you accurately represent
how big it should be,
it would look like this.
Now what happens when
you put them together?
This is the most
famous illustration
probably ever
created of human sex,
"The Copulation" by da Vinci.
"I expose to men the origin
of their first, and perhaps
second, reason for existing."
Interestingly, he
has the female just
a spurious little
scribbling right there.
The breasts connect
to the uterus,
reflecting the ancient
idea that menstrual blood
derives from breast milk.
And the semen ducts
are connected directly
to the brain, reflecting
the ancient idea that semen
derives from brain tissue.
Make of that what you will.
Now that idea held sway
for a long time though.
That when people
have sex, the penis
drives into a woman like
a sword into a sheath.
Most of us would
assume that that's
what it feels like, right.
So this is an image that
was made in the 1930s
by a Dutch anatomist, using a
glass dildo and some x-rays.
Now they updated this in 1999.
Another Dutch anatomist
got two people
to have sex inside
of an MRI scanner.
Has anyone here had an MRI?
Unbelievably claustrophobic,
can you imagine getting into one
and having sex with
somebody else in there?
How could you possibly do this?
Well, one of his
research assistants,
who was a scientist,
had previously
been a street acrobat.
And so had her boyfriend.
And so they were both very thin,
very flexible, and not prone
to stage fright.
This was pre-Viagra.
So they got in, and
they did the act of love
in the name of science.
And so what you can see
is that the penis does not
dive into a woman like
a sword into a sheath.
It bends at a 90 degree
angle like a boomerang.
And they didn't know
this until 1999.
But they didn't publish
this when they first made it
because they thought
it was too saucy.
They didn't publish it
until eight years later.
You've probably seen
this because when
these scientists put up the
video, it got millions of hits.
And it's still the most
viewed thing on the website
So let's go back to Masters and
Johnson, who I said were jerks.
No discussion of sex would
be complete without a mention
of homosexuality.
And this is the biggest reason
I think that they are jerks.
They made a lot of money
practicing something
called Conversion Therapy,
charging gay men money
to cure them of their disease.
Reprehensible.
You most know that
homosexuality was designated
as a pathology, as an
illness, until 1973
because it was put into the
"Diagnostics and Statistics
Manual" as a form
of mental illness.
This isn't just
an academic idea.
If something is in
the DSM, it means
that your doctor can diagnose
you and treat you accordingly.
And a lot of people
said, well we
don't think homosexuality
is a form of mental illness.
But as long as it
remained in that book,
it technically was--
until this guy came along,
Doctor E. Fryer.
I'm amazed how many people
don't know his name.
I didn't know his name until
I researched for this book.
I've spoken to experts
on homosexual culture
in this day and age
who've never heard of him.
Doctor E. Fryer was a
psychiatrist, and he was gay.
And he didn't
think he was crazy.
And he had gay patients who
he didn't think were crazy.
But he couldn't come
out of the closet
because, not only would
it ruin his personal life,
it would ruin his
professional life.
So he gave a passionate speech
at the American Psychiatric
Association's annual
general meeting in 1972
under the name
Doctor H. Anonymous,
wearing a rubber mask, a
fluffy wig, and a bow tie.
Now he said, I am gay.
I am a shrink.
I don't think I suffer from
mental illness, et cetera.
It's a wonderful
piece of writing.
Look it up.
You can read it.
It's great.
Now I wouldn't think
that wearing that get up
would convince people
that you're sane.
But it worked.
It worked.
And a year later they removed
homosexuality from the DSM.
Imagine how much
courage it took to sit
on that stage in that get up and
say everything he said, knowing
that at any moment someone
could take off his mask
and ruin his life.
To conclusion,
scientists are people.
People are flawed.
And sometimes smart people
think stupid things.
We often think that
scientists are merely
people who gather data and
present us with their best
approximation of the truth.
That's not true.
Scientists are people, and
they bring their prejudices
and their passions to the table.
And sometimes it takes
bravery and rebellion
to overturn
entrenched stupidity.
Now let's talk about drugs.
Normally when I talk about
drugs I'm at music festivals.
And so I'll say, oh what
kind of drugs do you like?
People go TCB, [INAUDIBLE],
na na na na na.
We're in Google, so I'm assuming
I can't do that with you guys.
Because cameras everywhere
will document it and send it
to Theresa May.
So I'll share a story.
I was in Scotland giving
a talk, this same talk.
Most of the people
were much older.
It was a literary festival.
They were quite buttoned up.
And so I wanted to do
a temperature check
on the audience.
It was like, OK, so do
you guys like any drugs?
Who likes drugs?
People went, woo.
And this old man in the front
row wearing a tweed suit
narrowed his eyes at
me and he said, acid.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, all right, I'm
preaching to the converted,
let's go.
I'm sure you all
can imagine what
science has done for drugs, new
chemistries, blah, blah, blah.
What I found way
more interesting
is how science has been
influenced by drugs, starting
with Nobel Prizes.
Crick and Watson, it
is reputed that they
got many of their insights due
to experimentation with LSD.
Now this is widely reported.
We did know that they
were party animals.
We're never really
going to know the truth
because Crick is dead.
However, we do know that
this jerk, Kary Mullis,
who got the Nobel Prize in 1992,
achieved his insight from LSD.
How many people here have
a biology background?
Mostly you're engineers.
OK, who here has heard of the
polymerase chain reaction?
So this got the Nobel Prize.
I do not have time to
explain how it works.
But it truly was a
stroke of genius.
Before he came up with
this in the 1980s,
it took geneticists years to
unravel the language of DNA.
With this simple
insight, just take it,
shatter it into 1,000
shards, read them separately,
and put them back together.
He really did earn
the Nobel Prize.
And he got this insight on LSD.
And I'm not making
this up because it's
in his autobiography,
"Dancing in the Mind Field."
"DNA chains coiled and floated.
Lurid blue and pink images
of electric molecules
injected themselves somewhere
between the mountain road
and my eyes."
What are the two most
important words in this quote?
Mountain road-- he was on
acid and he was driving.
And his wife was asleep
in the seat next to him.
So here we have Kary Mullis
with-- Ken Kesey with the Merry
Pranksters, you know, "Electric
Kool-Aid Acid Test," blah,
blah, blah, taking
acid and speed,
driving around, taking more acid
and speed and driving around.
A Nobel Prize-winning geneticist
did the exact same thing.
However, as I said, he's a
jerk because since then, he
has gone on to deny the science
of climate change and AIDS.
As I said, smart people
still think stupid things.
Now let's get to
a smart person who
is not a jerk, one of this
country's greatest scientists,
Humphry Davy, founder
of the Royal Society.
Now who here has ever had
a miner in their ancestry?
I'm sure many of you probably
do without even knowing it.
If you do, you're probably
alive because of this man.
Because he came up with this
thing, the Davy gas lamp.
Before he invented this,
this very simple mechanism
for burning methane gas
at a controlled rate,
miners were dying
by the thousands
from uncontrolled explosions
and tunnel collapse.
This very simple device
allowed for a small flame
to burn the methane at
a slow, controlled rate.
Now before he came up with this,
he was enamored with a drug.
What drug was that?
Nitrous oxide, laughing
gas, everyone's friend.
It's called laughing gas.
It's also called hippie crack.
It is, in some ways, a
very silly drug to do.
You get high for 30 seconds,
then your head hurts.
But it is scientifically and
medically very important.
This is the very first drug
that was made in a lab that
was put into the human brain.
Prior to this it was all
booze, mushrooms, plants,
things that grew.
This is the first time something
was made in the laboratory that
was put into the head.
It also was the very first
methodical investigation
of a drug.
This is the first time a
scientist sat down and took it
constantly, and gave
it to other people
constantly, and recorded
the dosage and the effects.
And lastly, but
not leastly, this
led to the gift of
anesthesia-- pain-free surgery.
Who here has had any kind
of pain-free surgery?
Pretty much everybody.
And we probably wouldn't
have it if it wasn't
for this wonderful invention.
Now Humphry Davy was
tasked with exploring
the virtues and the
qualities of various gases
at a facility in Bath.
And he tried a whole
bunch of different gases.
And one thing that
he did that I love
is that he tried everything
on himself first.
He wouldn't give
it to an animal.
it to other people.
He would try it
on himself first.
He was trying to explore
medical potentials.
At one point, he almost died
from carbon monoxide poisoning.
He didn't know what it would do.
And then he tried nitrous,
and he decided upon it
for his devoted study.
And devoted he was.
He came up with things like
this, silken bags inside
of wire cages.
He even built a
box that he could
get inside and have
his assistants pump
it full of the gas.
At one point he
consumed 80 quarts.
--teach any hippie kid today
how to do a drug properly.
And of course, like
hippies today, he
would write down what he
thought were salient thoughts.
"I existed in a world of newly
connected and newly modified
thoughts.
Nothing exists but thoughts."
And like drug
enthusiasts today, he
shared it with the cool cats.
Robert Southey, poet laureate--
"I am sure the air in heaven
must be this wonder
working gas of delight."
Samuel Taylor Coleridge--
"An unmingled pleasure. "
Anonymous-- "I felt like
the sound of a harp."
And this man said in
fewer words what others
would use thousands to say.
"I felt that I knew everything."
Now nitrous, like every other
drug, did not stay in the lab.
You can't keep something
fun secret forever.
It escaped.
Here's another drug that
escaped from the lab
around the same time, about
100 years later, cocaine.
We have, your friend
and mine-- before he
told you that you want to
have sex with your mother,
and he said that the clitoris
was irrelevant-- this man was
obsessed with cocaine.
After a German chemist
isolated the active component,
it sat on a lab shelf
for about 20 years
until a few people started
playing with it-- Freud.
Freud became obsessed with it.
And he stayed up
all night for weeks.
And he wrote a very long
diatribe called "Uber Coca,"
wonder coke, saying basically,
cocaine is really amazing.
Everybody should do cocaine.
It's really good
for your creativity.
I think everybody
should do a lot of it.
We'd have some really
great insights, et cetera.
[LAUGHTER]
It was, like a lot of drug
manuals, it was very boring.
But what it did do is it
led to the popularisation
of this drug.
And most people think of the
Victorians as being uptight.
Nope, the Victorians
loved drugs.
They loved opiates.
And they fell in
love with cocaine.
They put it in everything.
And it was sold at Harrods They
put it into lozenges, syrups,
candy for children
because children
need help becoming hyperactive.
They put it into a wine
called Vin Mariani,
8% coke, 10% booze,
blessed by a pope,
and beloved by Queen Victoria.
Now the Victorian
indulgence in drugs
is scientifically very relevant.
It's not just funny.
It's relevant because this led
to the discovery, directly led
to the discovery, of
neurotransmitters.
And this is not just my opinion.
This is based on
a wonderful book
you can read called "Drugged"
by Richard Miller, who
is a neuroscientist and
a chemist in Chicago.
The reason drugs led to the
discovery of neurotransmitters,
things like dopamine,
serotonin, oxytocin,
these things are
mimicked by drugs.
Drugs mimic serotonin.
They mimic dopamine.
So for example, here we have
psilocybin on the left, which
comes from magic mushrooms.
There we have
serotonin on the right.
Psilocybin mimics it.
And what it does is it
goes into your brain cells
and it invades the receptors
that are built for your body's
natural chemicals.
That is how most drugs work.
So scientists and the
average philosopher
who was experimenting
with drugs at the time
thought, well, how can something
that comes from a mushroom,
or how can something that
comes from a tobacco plant,
or how can something
that comes from coffee
change the way I feel?
If you think about it, it
is a scientific puzzle.
And so it was drug
indulgence that led to this.
And so what happened was this.
The typical route of
investigation went like this.
Scientists would map
the drug, and then they
would find the neurotransmitter
that it mimics.
So the first time
that it happened,
it was because of nicotine.
The same drug that has killed
untold millions of people
from tobacco, this led to
the very first discovery
of a neurotransmitter.
So nicotine was mapped in 1843.
It wasn't until the 1970s
that scientists tracked down
the receptor in the
brain that it fits into,
which normally binds to
something called acetylcholine.
They named the
receptor, the keyhole,
they named it the nicotinic
acetylcholine receptor.
We named our body
part after a drug.
And this is not the
first time this happened.
Cannabis 1964, it was mapped.
The endocannabinoids, your
body's own natural painkillers,
were mapped in 1990, and
named after cannabis.
Morphine, 1805 it was mapped.
The endorphins were not
tracked down until 1975,
and again, named after the drug.
This even goes for
molecular energy.
Caffeine, which won the
Nobel Prize, mapped in 1881.
And I personally think caffeine
deserves a Nobel Prize.
ATP, what it mimics, the
molecular currency of energy,
was not mapped until 1929.
And this is my favorite example.
LSD and serotonin.
It was not until
experimentation with LSD
around this time
that people started
to think that serotonin may
have a role in the mind.
80% of the serotonin
in your body
is found in your
gut, not your brain.
So people didn't think
it had a role in the head
until a couple of different
teams, one in Glasgow,
one in Baltimore, did some
chemical detective work.
At one point carting
10,000 buckets of cow blood
from an abattoir to a
lab in Baltimore to prove
that serotonin has
a role in the brain.
And we can thank this
man, Albert Hoffman.
This is the man who made LSD.
Did you know the man who
made LSD, a Swiss nerd,
lived to be 102.
And he took acid till he was 96.
This is him on his
hundredth birthday.
And I know people
who were there.
And they say that he
indeed twinkled like a star
and flirted with all the girls.
Now he was not a hippie.
He was a nerd.
He was a bigger nerd
than anyone in his room.
He was the biggest nerd
that ever nerded a nerd.
He worked for Sandoz
Chemicals in Switzerland.
his entire career.
He was a company man
and a total square.
And he did not experiment with
drugs at all until he made LSD.
He made it by accident.
He had spent 10 years crushing
up the shells of chiton,
of crustaceans, exploring
other potential applications
of other chemicals until he
accidentally made LSD, got some
on his fingers,
and rode a bicycle
home in 1943 in Switzerland,
and experienced the world's
first acid trip.
It's very famous.
It's known as bicycle day.
And you can get tabs of
acid with its picture on it.
Now what was he actually trying
to do when he accidentally
made LSD?
Does anyone know?
Any guesses?
It will surprise you.
He actually was trying to come
up with treatments to save
the lives of pregnant women.
That was what he spent
most of his career doing,
drugs for obstetrics.
And he did succeed.
He made something called
methergine, which is still
one of the most widely
used drugs in obstetrics
to prevent the death of women
from post-partum hemorrhaging.
The reason he came
across LSD is because he
was experimenting with this.
This is called the ergot fungus.
This is a filthy black fungus
that infest fields of rye.
It's a parasite.
And it's a very
toxic, toxic fungus.
And it produces something called
St. Anthony's Fire, gangrene,
hallucinations.
You can actually have limbs
drop off from gangrene
from St. Anthony's
Fire if you eat
rye that has been
infected with this fungus.
The largest outbreak in Europe,
and this happened frequently
throughout the medieval
era, killed 10,000 people
in Aquitaine in 926.
The most recent
outbreak of ergot fungus
was in 1926 in Russia.
And it's called
St. Anthony's Fire.
It has its own saint.
And this is a medieval wood cut.
You can see there's
hands and feet strung up
from the ceiling.
That's because
sometimes peasants
would have multiple limbs,
even all four, drop off
from eating this fungus.
But it has other qualities.
It has what are called
uterotonic qualities.
It can have actions
on the uterus.
So midwives knew that if
they use small amounts of it,
they could have useful
properties in childbirth.
So what Hoffman wanted to do
was to find synthetic analogs
of this that wouldn't have
the toxic properties that
could kill you but would
still be useful on the uterus.
So if you remember
anything about LSD,
please remember, it comes
from a saint-- Sorry,
it comes from a parasite.
It has its own saint.
And it was born in
the quest to save
the lives of pregnant women.
Now when Hoffman tried
it, he didn't think
people would do it for fun.
Bless his heart.
He thought it would
only be useful
to artists and to scientists.
And he believed that it
could be for psychiatry
what the microscope
was for biology
and the telescope for astronomy.
Now, he sincerely
hoped it would only
be used by psychiatrists
and scientists.
Unfortunately, as I said, you
can't keep something fun secret
forever.
Once it got into the
hands of the hippies,
especially this guy, Dr. Timothy
Leary, most known for "Turn on,
tune in, drop out," it
became highly popular.
To give you an idea of
just how popular it was
and how much this
scared the authorities,
Nixon called him the most
dangerous man in America.
Which is incredible, because
everything he ever wrote is
unbearably boring .
This is one of my favorite
photographs from the era.
Did you know that the
American government actually
was considering
dropping bombs made
of acid onto enemy combatants as
a means of destabilizing them?
They had no idea how ironic
it would be when they
wrote, drop acid, not bombs.
So for a while you
couldn't experiment
with psychedelics on humans.
You can only do it on animals.
This is one of the most famous
illustrations that you can see.
You probably have seen this
on like BuzzFeed or some crap.
It's true though.
And this research
was funded by NASA.
NASA in the 1970s, they
gave drugs to spiders
to get a rough idea of
how toxic they were.
So here we have marijuana
on the top left,
which is pretty competent.
But it looks like the spider
just gave up halfway through.
The most messed up web is
caffeine, bottom right.
Which is a bit disturbing.
And here we have
LSD, bottom left.
Which is basically
perfect, but broad.
Make of that what you will.
Now you could experiment
on humans legally, and not
animals, if you did what?
If you made something brand new.
Like this guy, who you
probably have heard of.
He died last year,
Alexander Shulgin.
Alexander Shulgin was a
scientist working for Dow.
And he then decided to
quit making pesticides
and set up shop in his
garden to only make
illegal drugs after a
student gave him some MDMA.
He figured out how
to re-engineer MDMA,
and he gave the
world the recipe.
If it wasn't for
this man, we probably
wouldn't have rave culture.
It was first created
by Merck in 1912.
It wasn't until he tried it
and gave the world the recipe,
which is still freely
available online, erowid.com.
Now what I love about
Shulgin is that he
made thousands of chemicals.
And like Humphry
Davy before hand,
he tried everything
on himself first.
He wouldn't give
it to an animal.
He would do it on himself first.
And the word for
that is chivalry.
And then if he thought it was
fun, he'd give it to his wife.
And if she thought
it was fun they
would share it
with their friends.
So he figured out how to
synthesize MDMA in 1976.
He created more
than 2000 chemicals
in his time, of which
200 were psychoactive.
So carrying on, not much
happened because of this jerk.
But today we're experiencing
something called
the psychedelic Renaissance.
I'll run through
this very quickly.
But it's very important.
All drugs are
double-edged swords.
Whether you're talking about
caffeine, alcohol, nicotine,
psychedelics, every drug
has good and bad properties.
There's no such thing as
a bad drug or a good drug.
It's about how you use it.
Think about morphine.
We've never made a
painkiller more effective
than what plants can give us.
Now these dangerous,
very powerful drugs
can have useful properties
in the right place,
at the right time,
on the right person.
Very briefly, they're
looking at how
to use LSD to treat
alcoholism, psilocybin
to treat obsessive
compulsive disorder
MDMA for post-traumatic
stress disorder.
The list goes on and on and on.
And some of this
is crowd sourced.
So for example, people who
have high levels of autism,
like adults who are
high functioning,
found that taking
MDMA on a weekend
out with their friends
in the late 90s at raves
helped them with their
social interactions.
They lobbied for legitimate
research into this
and they won.
And there are real
scientific studies
being conducted to look
at how to use MDMA to help
high functioning autistics.
Moreover, people who suffer
from cluster headaches, which
are known to be excruciatingly
painful and very hard to treat,
found that taking LSD
alleviated their symptoms.
And they lobbied for legitimate
science, and they won.
Crowd source science.
So, could psychedelics be for
the mind with the telescope
was for astronomy?
That remains to be seen, but
at least now we can find out.
As David Nutt puts it,
drugs are an important part
of our evolutionary history.
And we cannot ignore them.
Now, last subject, music,
which is my favorite subject.
As I always say, music has
never killed any of my friends
or destroyed my home.
It's my favorite subject of all.
And I can rip through
this very quickly
in the time we have left.
Because I think it
is the best subject
in the whole wide world.
So what is music?
It's a biological puzzle.
Give me a guess.
What do you think music is?
Define it.
Come on, this is a
room of smart people.
AUDIENCE: The
universal language.
ZOE CORMIER: That's an excellent
answer, the universal language.
That's a good one.
No one's said that
before actually.
Most of the time
people say things
like this, organized sound.
OK, yeah, fine, music
is organized sound.
But so is an alarm clock.
That's not music.
Beautiful math-- music
is indeed mathematical.
And it is certainly beautiful.
But there are many
forms of mathematics
that are not musical.
Music, above all, is
an exquisite illusion.
It's an illusion that
your brain makes for you.
It doesn't exist in the
objective world around you.
It is a subjective
reality that your brain
creates for you
inside your head,
and only inside your head.
The best way that
I can explain this
is that there is a
condition called amusia.
This means no music.
People who have
amusia tend to be
perfectly intelligent
in every other capacity.
There is nothing wrong
with their hearing.
They just don't hear the
same composition of harmonies
that most other people hear.
And it's very, very common.
In fact, 4% of the
human population
appears to not hear music.
There's about a dozen
different forms.
Some people can hear timbre,
but they can't perceive rhythm.
Some people can perceive rhythm,
but they can't perceive timbre.
If you think that you
may have some inability
to perceive music in the
way that other people do,
you can take an online test
from scientists at McGill
who study this.
They've studied this
for a very long time.
And there are some
famous people who
seem to have had amusia,
including Che Guevara.
Now in the rest of
us, what's going on
to create the
perception of music?
For people who have amusia,
it tends to sound like noise.
It sounds like unstructured,
just bothersome noises.
But in the rest of us
our brains do something
to create the
perception of color,
and emotion, and meaning.
Why is that?
Because, it's a
cliche, but it's true.
The most complicated
thing in the universe
is inside your head.
It's not even any
computer in this building,
no matter how great you
might imagine them to be.
It's not as great as
what's inside your head.
There are more
possible connections
between the neurons in
your head than there
are atoms in the universe.
And it's an oft repeated
figure, but it's true.
Now scientists used to
think that music was just
a byproduct of language.
They just thought that
language was the key thing that
made the human brain
special and that music
was basically sonic junk food.
That it just took
advantage of the structures
in your head that were built for
grammar, patterns, repetition.
Steven Pinker, a very
famous neuroscientist,
said in the 1980s that
music was only, quote,
"auditory cheesecake.
What benefit could there be
to diverting time and energy
to making plinking noises.
As far as biological cause
and effect are concerned,
music is useless."
To quote Vesalius, "useless."
A French scientist went
even further, Dan Sperber.
He called it an evolutionary
parasite, a parasite.
OK, let's look at
this logically.
Yes, when you look
in the brain and what
happens when you
listen to music,
or when you speak,
or read, there
are some structures that
are shared in common
but not all of them.
They overlap.
And you can have amusia and
still perceive language.
But you can also fail
to perceive language
in what is called aphasia.
Say if you have a stroke and
you can still perceive music.
The most famous
example is this guy.
Vissarion Shebalin was a
composer who had a stroke.
He lost the ability to speak.
But he could still compose
symphonies, not just
melodies, entire symphonies.
And he spoke to his wife through
music for about 15 years.
Now other things in the
realm of neuroscience
can teach us about music.
When neuroscientists
finally looked at the brain,
and when you listen
to music, they
found that there isn't just
one spot in the brain that
responds to music.
It seems to involve
every single component
of your brain, the new stuff at
the front-- the frontal cortex,
ancient things at the back-- the
cerebellum, bits on the side,
deep inside, ancient structures
associated with memory,
with emotion.
Front to back, top to bottom,
left to right, everything, more
parts of your brain than
any other human activity.
And this is why
it is an illusion.
That's why.
This is this magical thing
that happens inside your head.
This is unique perception.
It even engages
parts of your brain
at the very back, ancient
parts of your brain,
including your
spinal cord, which
is not stimulated by a spoken
language or random noises.
But it is stimulated by music.
Moreover, coming back
to our friends drugs,
music can produce
releases of endorphins
and dopamine inside your
brain in the same way
that marijuana, sex, and
cocaine and heroin can.
You do not need any drugs.
All you need is your iPod.
It is an auditory sex toy.
And Apple might want
to phase it out,
but I still think it's the best.
And this is my favorite little
tidbit from neuroscience.
Music makes every neuron in
your head pulse in synchrony.
Nothing else does
this to your brain
as far as we know,
absolutely nothing.
And when they discovered this,
they called it a wow moment.
Moreover, every single
human culture makes music.
Not every single human culture
has the number zero, writing,
architecture, agriculture,
stratified social structures.
Every single human culture
in the world makes music.
It is so ancient, some
of the oldest artifacts
that we have ever found have
been musical instruments.
This is a 40,000 year old flute.
And it's a flute.
This was found in Slovenia.
It's made from the
bone of a bear.
So imagine how much
further back in time
we were making drums
or just singing.
Moreover, as I'm
sure most of you who
have kids, or have spent
time with kids, can attest,
babies love music.
There is a language
called motherese
that's found in every
single culture in the world.
When people speak
to their babies
in a lilting sing-song
fashion, every single culture
in the world does this.
And we know that kids love
music and that they learn things
better through music,
such as the ABC song.
This, by the way,
is a photograph
of my brother at about
two and 1/2 years old.
He also works for Google.
He's in Toronto.
If you guys use Twitter
or Google+ or anything,
Ben Cormier.
I love that photo.
Now, who here knows the
phrase retail therapy?
I think it's one of
the ickiest pairings
in the English language.
Buy stuff you don't
need to feel better.
Music therapy though,
using music as medicine--
and I'm not just talking about
hippie dippie using music
to feel better in some sort
of wishy-washy fashion--
I'm talking about real,
double-blind constructed
scientific studies where they're
looking at using music to help
real human conditions, such
as Parkinson's, helping people
with their tremors, helping
people with memory problems,
Alzheimer's.
In the same way that kids
learn to speak using music,
we can help people who have
lost language with music.
We can help people
regain the ability
to speak and read better
if it's aided with music
than by language alone.
So obviously it has
some deep roots.
How might music have
evolved in the first place?
Could it have an
adaptive benefit?
Could it have been selected for?
What's the most obvious answer?
Come on, it's a gimme.
The most obvious answer, sex.
Darwin thought so.
"I conclude that musical
notes and rhythm were first
acquired by the male or
female progenitors of mankind
for the sake of charming
the opposite sex," Darwin.
What is the less obvious answer?
Social bonding, using music to
communicate with other people.
In most cultures, music
is not a spectator sport.
It's something that you
do with other people
together as a communal activity.
And we have found
that when people
sing in choirs, when
they sing together,
it produces the release of
a hormone called oxytocin.
It's also known as
the trust hormone
that's involved
in breastfeeding,
and released by orgasm.
And it's released when you
sing with other people.
Now if we weren't able to
bond with other people,
and most importantly, to keep
a rhythm with other people,
we couldn't have done
things like this.
We wouldn't be able to
lift giant structures.
coordinate our efforts
and build monumental
architecture
in the pre-industrial age
if it wasn't for the fact
that we can keep a beat.
Obviously you need
10,000 slaves too.
But being able to do this all
at once, heave ho, heave ho.
If we didn't have
music, we couldn't
have built the pyramids.
So could we have formed
large complex societies
without music?
Could music predate language
as a form of communication?
Would we ever have evolved
language without music?
Would we be human without music?
Last question, do
animals make music?
If animal could make
music, what kind of music
would animal make?
Animal beat drum!
No one ever gets that.
Some real scientists decided
to investigate this question.
Do marmosets like music?
Obviously birds
and whales, animals
that use vocal
communication, they
enjoy some forms of
sonic composition.
But the question remains, do
primates, do other primates,
like music?
So, a guy named
Josh McDermott, who
was a club DJ, who then
became a neuroscientist,
decided to investigate
this in a serious fashion.
And he made a little
multi-room rave.
And he had different
speakers at different ends
of this little rave playing
different kinds of music,
classical, grunge, techno,
jazz, anything you want.
What kind of music do
you think the marmosets
preferred, depending on
where they went in the maze?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ZOE CORMIER: Jungle?
No, the answer is silence.
The answer is silence.
No matter what, they
always preferred silence.
So he concluded that
marmosets don't like music.
Clearly we're the only
primate that does.
Other scientists
have said, well,
clearly songbirds like music.
--whales, blah blah blah.
It becomes a big
semantic argument.
What constitutes music?
Blah blah blah.
One scientist decided to
draw a line in the sand.
And he said, OK, lots of
animals have very interesting
sonic compositions.
But only we can keep a beat.
Only humans can do this.
[RHYTHMIC CLAPPING]
And when he said this, he
got a flurry of angry emails.
The internet unleashed its rage.
No, no no, my dog loves
Snoop Dogg, na na na.
My cat loves the Pussycat
Dolls, na na na na.
He said fine, fine, fine.
If you have a pet, and you
think your pet can keep a beat.
And you live within 200
miles of the San Diego area.
I will pay for your travel.
You can come to my lab.
And I will test it.
And you've probably
seen this because it
has been viewed umpteen
million times on YouTube.
This is Snowball.
But he kept a beat
so accurately,
this was written up in a
scientific paper published
in 2009 in the "Annals of the
New York Academy of Sciences,"
the world's first animal
shown to keep a beat.
If you like this, you can
see videos of Snowball
rocking out to "Thriller,"
by Michael Jackson,
and the Backstreet Boys.
And when they took the music and
slowed it down and sped it up,
he could still keep a beat.
He wasn't just
following his owner.
And this was a scientific
first, because of the fury
of the internet.
Now, just because
Snowball can keep
a beat doesn't mean that
all birds can keep a beat.
He's a pet and he's
been habituated
to his owner's habits.
But what we do know is that,
among primates, we are alone.
We are the musical monkey.
We are also the
druggiest monkey.
And we are certainly
a randy monkey.
As I said, we always think about
our higher cognitive capacities
as to being the key to
what makes us human.
And we denigrate
these three activities
as being basic, and
primitive, and unimportant.
But in fact, the more
you look at them,
the more you realize that they
are spectacular components
of the human condition.
Yes, other animals get high,
and rut, and make noise.
But we have taken all
three to the next level.
And we wouldn't be human
if it wasn't for them.
And moreover, being
naughty has led
to some of science's most
important discoveries.
There is redemptive value
in being rebellious.
Hedonistic impulses have
informed our highest pursuits.
And there is nothing
wrong with having fun.
Don't ever let anyone
tell you otherwise.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: We have a
few minutes for questions.
So please raise your hands
and wait for the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ZOE CORMIER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
It was awesome.
My name is Edyta
and I wanted to ask,
what happens when
we imagine music?
So you were talking
about [INAUDIBLE] can
amusic people imagine music?
ZOE CORMIER: Yes, that's
a really good question.
They have found that when you
sit inside a brain scanner,
the pattern of activity
inside your brain
when you imagine listening
to a particular song
is pretty much identical to what
happens as to when you actually
hear that song.
So you can just make the
music inside your head
whenever you want.
It looks the same.
As for amusia, as
I said, there's
a dozen different forms.
And most people who have amusia,
they just find music confusing.
And they don't really understand
what it is that the rest of us
like.
It depends on the
different kind you have.
As I said, there's a
dozen different kinds,
because there's different
bits of your brain
that could be malfunctioning.
And there have been
cases of people
who have trained themselves
to perceive music differently.
And some people who don't
perceive timbre, for example.
They still enjoy rhythm.
So if you have
that, go to a rave.
My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
given how great, obviously,
sex and drug are, what do you
attribute their social stigmas?
ZOE CORMIER: --the
social stigma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ZOE CORMIER: That's
a very good--
that's the question I was forced
to think about an awful lot.
I could quote my mother again.
She said, to the
authorities, sometimes just
the thought of somebody
else somewhere having fun
is just intolerable.
Sex, I mean there are some
biological reasons why
sex would have a stigma.
Because it is dangerous.
And it does spread disease.
Or it does break your heart
and it is a touchy subject.
It's not easy to see other
people doing it all the time.
I mean, I hated researching sex.
I absolutely hated it.
I hated reading
about it constantly
when I was sitting at
home, dead sober by myself.
As for drugs, again,
there's a realistic reason
why it might have a stigma.
Because it can be dangerous.
But your guess is
as good as mine.
I mean, what do you think?
That's not really a
scientific question
as it is a political one.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: My question is sort
of connected with that one.
Can you talk a little
bit about-- I'm
sorry this is a
very broad question.
Can you talk a little
bit about the connection
between the science of drugs
and the criminalization
and the more recent
decriminalization
of some drugs.
ZOE CORMIER: Yeah, sure.
It's completely
nonsensical, and it's silly.
I mean, the war on drugs
has obviously failed.
Everybody knows
that it's failed.
And the scientific basis
for what drugs are illegal
and what drugs are not
illegal is not very sound.
And the psychoactive
substances bill is ridiculous.
I'm not sure if many
of you know about this,
but the bill that they're
putting through where they want
to make all legal highs,
except for tea, coffee,
and alcohol, and tobacco.
That's the only
handful of things
that they're saying
that you should
be able to buy over the counter
in any way, shape, or form.
Technically, that would prohibit
you from smelling a rose.
Technically it
would-- there have
been lawyers who have
written about this
in terms of the
neurological effects you
get from other things
that produce pleasure.
As to why they want to
clamp down on these things
and why-- I mean, I understand
why they want to do it.
Because they don't like the idea
of kids doing drugs in fields
unattended.
Why they think they'll be
successful is beyond me.
There's no way that
this is going to work.
Prohibition has never worked.
MALE SPEAKER: Any
more questions?
In that case, please
join me in thanking Zoe.
ZOE CORMIER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]